on the on the a depression ad for a
moment ago did you tell the Ukrainian
leader that they would happy Aid only if
they investigated jo5 Nana's family no I
did of a certain prosecutor Joe Biden
said but because you are a favorite you
in particular here thank you
little people you don't want to report
that I didn't do it and you could I hope
you didn't be able to see it ball
because I didn't do it everybody's
looking for that call and keep going
when you do it because wait to see the
code you're going to be very surprised
no Big Joe Biden let me do it let me
just what Joe Biden is the one that did
a very very bad thing what he said that
and I think it was 1.2 billion dollars
he was gonna get unless they get rid of
a prosecutor who was investigating his
son and the company that has done works
for then you also say how much money did
his son make from the Ukraine then ask
another question how much money did his
son break from China based on energy he
does nothing about energy so why did he
leave China why did he leave Ukraine
with all this money so Joe Biden was
very dishonest now when you see the call
when you see it I hope you see it
frankly you will find out that I did not
do that at all and you'll be very
disappointed when you say it it's really
good disgrace it really is a situation
where it just shows the press you've had
such a bad week between justice
Kavanaugh and this and other things it's
showing how dishonest so many members of
the press are not all of you but so many
members of the press are so totally
dishonest but this is a case I hope you
get to see the call because your
question you will see I did not ask for
did I did not make a statement that you
have to do this
give you a I wouldn't do that I wouldn't
do that with that being said what I want
is I want you deal with giving a lot of
money away to Ukraine and other places
you want to see a country that's going
to be not corrupt the president is a
good man
he got elected and the fact that he was
going to get rid of corruption in
Ukraine that's I think the primary
reason he got elected so he gets elected
on the basis of ending corruption in
Ukraine well I think that's good and
that's what I want to see
but when Biden does a thing like that
then there's still corruption and that's
not good I can do it very easily but I'd
rather not do it from the standpoint of
all of the other conversations I have I
may do it because it was a very innocent
call or both his part of my way - very
nice call it was really a congratulatory
call because he is just one it was just
confirmed and he's the new president and
I think he's going to do an excellent
job but remember he got elected on the
basis of the biggest part was corruption
in his campaign and so he wants the same
thing that he's looking for the same
thing as I am he did a very good job was
a very nice call I hope you get to see
it and I hope you get to see it soon